who did you play in that i don't know i  think i was just a waitress at the olive  garden yeah oh my god that's right  you were you were a waitress you were a  waitress  we might have taken that yeah  and been like hey do a version of that  character for play play waitress in this  thing too and then play a waitress for  the rest of your life just like they'll  scream waitress at you for the rest of  your life that's so funny i didn't  remember that you had played a waitress  at the olive garden in our first thing  and then you were the waitress in the  coffee shop so let's just reveal the  waitress's name right now is should we  all say it on the count of three one two  three  [Music]  you